so I
know I'm oriented this way towards
her and I know on the first move I'm
going to bring her over
here I know I should face her
then so at some point there's a degree
of
rotation I know
that I know that there's certain joint
alignments or joint relationships I have
to keep intact
so the foot
knee hip shoulder elbow
wrist I don't I'm not going to do this
change the relationship
here I'm not going to do this change the
KNE to foot
relationship
okay I also know that she has y aspect
to her
movement so let's start there young
aspect I don't hold her
here okay and try to turn her from there
because as I feel the whatever y value
you feel and as I start to
turn it's
increasing
until the grip comes back towards me do
you see that so right here it's that X
and here's x + y you see that and then x
- y That's she falls in so that that
would not be a harmonization then
there's a clash right in right there
okay so you push harder and you'll see
the clash as it makes her shoulder and
everything go
back but this is also
wrong is now I violated the elbow
shoulder relationship
see okay so what you do
instead is you shift onto the back foot
so as you come
in and I shift onto the
back and I start to work off of this
qua okay this foot has no weight on
it this is the beginning of me allowing
it to not work
against the rotation I leave my foot
there and I turn that's me working again
against the foot but when I take weight
off of it it's very light to
nothing
okay and we already started
absorbing and since the right foot is
slightly south of the left foot your
deviation already started just on the
weight shift you see how you slightly
came that way without the turn
W okay
now
reestablish The Joint Harmony you
see don't work against that
foot like
that Margaret or a having to roll it
in BO foot free the front foot and the
front foot moves to maintain the harmony
you're
here hold
turn okay we're just going to work on
that
part hold
turn turn
shoulder elbow Harmony jacked up and
there's a lot of pressure on my knee
foot
Harmony there's no weight on that foot
what
I'm on the
ground okay all you're in that ballp
part the elbow
is going to guide when that foot turns
it turns with the
elbow and hence you'll never end up like
this
see like that here you got
crunched
okay so
shift you've already started moving
slightly that way close the
quaw the foot moves with the elbow and
you maintain that Harmony shoulder elbow
hip knee
foot wait over here so this is free to
move moves with the elbow
it is not your power
foot you're not turning
that to create rotational torque and
you're definitely not leaving it in
place and just using your arms nor are
you just getting out of the way of
someone that's
pushing okay the same thing if she was
pulling right she's pulling I ground on
the back foot and close the
core
okay the technique though she's
pushing he
attention to the foot elbow relationship
my weight on this
foot
okay now we can do the next thing
one and you can see that when I shift
here that this quaw this foot
this knee this shoulder they have
the organization that I
want now I reorganize the other side
okay you can see that as I do
this I come back and now I'm on the
other
side and I'm going around the
energy boom around the energy and she's
on the outside of that to
me okay meaning you're not going to be
here stay on this pivot point and then
stay
here as her
energy goes by I went on the other side
see this is key because in my opinion
this is how you how Ed me actually
functions in a fight the idea that
you're
there get in
how and then I move here past you into
the back of you it never
works can't I can't get to the back
of doesn't
work I need you to pass me halfway and
now I can pass you the rest of the way
that works okay and that's what we're
doing here one and I go to the other
side one and I'm on the other side I'm
on the other foot
now this fall this
fall this
this that allows me to close so if I
stay here on this claw or's I'd have to
violate the harmonies but when I go to
the other quaw it closes
and I can keep it again foot knee elbow
shoulder so just like I'm on this claw
here same thing when I go here and I go
here I'm on this claw
here just want you to understand that
you've pass her she's past you in the
weight shifting
okay well now that happens before we
adem okay try another pointer to help
out so unweighted
rotation is done on the
heel this is weighted this is unweighted
see you pivot you rotated on the
heel weighted
rotation that's where I'm going to shift
here is done on the ball of the foot on
the ball of the
foot do you guys see that don't don't go
ball the foot here because you're
waiting and it's supposed to be
unweighted so it's on the heel and then
likewise you're going to reweight
it and rotate on it it goes on the ball
of the
foot and again guess what this one does
when get rotates it's going to be on the
heel
okay
ball
heel
heel ball
heel careful you don't use the ball foot
there it's going to waight it you're
going to hurt your
knee there's nothing on
it then there's something on it there's
nothing on
this I'm not asking you to exaggerate it
I'm demonstrating it so you could see it
okay so when you go you probably never
noticed it but that's what's happening
okay now we do the eding so boom I'm on
this side right and now I can enter
freely into
that we don't want to push on our knee
that means I'm entering into y space so
I take you away and I enter into that
space bre space right there so that
little turn that we did here right when
I go under this
foot I use it to turn now into the EDI
so you don't stay in place okay I had
you stay in place so you have the
mechanics but when you come around to
this side you enter into that
turn so you have to stay weighted a
little longer
here and you turn on the ball the foot
there
right right here is three that's what
you need okay that's where you enter you
don't enter
into pushing
on there's nothing here you got light
okay the bigger mistake is that when you
get here you iner you violate everything
we just did this side
Mar and you did this again and you're
trying to turn so when you
incher you
incher
turning you can step just like when I'm
here and I
reposition my
foot same thing
I'm going to turn my foot turn my foot
it's going to drill down so it's on the
ball of the
foot turn your
foot step on a
turn turn on the
ball boom step on a turn boom
single Pivot Point okay
try now I'm
stepping okay it's not weighted yet as I
weight it I go on the ball of foot and I
turn
step that's Ed
me I said Don't Step
here step keep the relationship now
you're going to use the qua to
turn this fo you shift from the ball of
foot you don't want to
enter and do undo everything we're
trying to
do so as you're going around I inter
turn and now I do that second part we
instructed on I have to get to the other
side of the force
equation to rotate
the
enter turn and shift my weight to that
foot
that's the end of the
rotation now the foot steps back and
become come
one in other
words you should not go
around like that should be no more
rotation War technique reconcile boom
and
okay TR so your degree of
rotation can't
violate
those organization between those joints
okay and you're that means you have a
ceiling to what you can do because if
you over rotate one joint or two joints
they'll fall out of a harmonious align
with the other
joints what we do instead is this claw
gives me we we didn't measure it Andrew
said approximately 15° so you get an
extra
15° of lateral or
rotational um movement okay so you're
doing your Technique uh in Su waza
that's how much rot you have that's it
you you're not you're not going to turn
your waist like this do you see you're
not going to do that okay uh so I can
keep my feet in place and get that much
angle on him if I ever wanted more
that's when I would have to move that
whole relationship
okay so when you
see as we started this
you only are
allowed that movement and when you stay
weighted on this front
foot and then you rotate you went way
past that you see if you if you're
thinking on that other technique you can
see that I don't what it is my knee kind
of moves inside the width of my foot in
that same thing you have to go way past
that to get this weird alignment and way
past that to get your arch to roll in
okay you guys get that okay so you do
you do
have this but it's only 15° and it's
from the Quad it's not from the waist
okay it's not from the from your hips
turning
either okay so if you pay attention
that's what we're doing all
I I want him to go past this do you see
you get that I want him to go past that
this one is at its max if it goes more
it's going to push the knee out of that
foot alignment making my foot come up so
I go to the other quad you see and then
I have that 15° there we want to make
more
movement so we step on it you see now
you have your 15° oh I need more so I
can rotate the foot and I keep the
harmonies and then I step into that
space
okay when you take this
foot step into it don't move where you
jacked it all up okay you only have 15°
to play
with
boom boom turn you're now on the other
side you now achiev ten con I am on the
other side of the Yang aspect okay step
where you maintain the harmony come over
here you twisted it
okay boom
[Music]
boom
15°
okay okay so if you notice we started
here West and as I'm doing the technique
we're going to end up you see at North
South okay and now we've met the 90
degree fluctuation all right and the ten
con
happens right here that's the ten con
this is just icing so right here is
where you're in the
dock and you're not throwing on the 180
anymore
[Music]
so what I did is because of step back
into what everyone understands this
kindo handc is not the ten con the ten
con happened here when you're on the
other side of the Yang aspect okay
didn't I could step that foot there then
I got 15° of qua that's what I used to
bring them in and 15 going back the
other
way same con happen
sh can't happen
[Music]
here right try